vemos qué pasa esta semana es una semana
bastante crítica puesto que se eligen a
las personas que van a participar en las
primarias como presidenciables estamos
en un año completamente electoral en
chile el que va a haber cuatro
elecciones más en los próximos meses y
desde luego esto marca tendencia como
marca tendencia el hecho de que el
propio presidente sebastián piñera haya
reconocido públicamente la derrota que
impone estos resultados electorales
especialmente en cuanto a los
constituyentes y que dijera el mismo que
esto les marca o les impone una
reflexión en reflexión profunda porque
la ciudadanía se está desconectando de
los partidos políticos fueron unas
elecciones históricas en la que
participaron más de 16.000 candidatos
para elegir 2.700 cargos y también en la
composición de alcaldes vemos la entrada
del partido comunista por ejemplo en la
municipalidad de santiago y también del
frente amplio que las elecciones pasadas
no había estado constituido de una forma
tan significativa y ahora apareció con
más listas y tiene algunas de las
alcaldías importantes de santiago en
algunos casos con
un porcentaje de los votos bastante
significativo así que vemos un mapa en
el que la izquierda se impone más en
cuanto también a alcaldías y concejales
y muchas personas salieron ayer a
celebrar en los barrios donde se
produjeron estos sorprendentes nuevos
cargos electos